filipinas no se termina de recuperar del
tifón más fuerte del mundo en 2020
cuando ya se prepara para banco en la
noche del miércoles las provincias del
sur del país fueron azotadas por esta
tormenta tropical banco golpeó manila o
con vientos de 320 kilómetros por hora
aunque ahora esto se redujeron a 125
kilómetros por hora los ojos están
puestos en que el tifón golpeará este
jueves a manila la capital mientras los
filipinos ven otra vez sus calles y sus
casas inundadas
es la segunda vez la primera fue durante
el tifón mandoi pero no esperaba que
fuera así mi esposo y yo estábamos
acostados cuando una conmoción con mis
vecinos y mi esposo salió él vio eso el
agua ya estaba tan alta así que salimos
corriendo y solo traje mi re polonia mi
culo al lado aunque el tifón banco
todavía no ha llegado a manila la
capital filipina ya suspendió los vuelos
y el transporte público por las fuertes
lluvias los habitantes de las costas de
la ciudad también se preparan y ya
comenzaron a evacuar sus casas
hemos aconsejado a nuestros residentes
que evacuen temprano ya que nuestra
aldea está propensa a fuertes vientos e
inundaciones paga máximas la tormenta
banco ya deja por lo menos una persona
muerta en el sur del país pero no se
compara con el tifón goni que dejó 25
personas muertas seis desaparecidas y
miles de hogares destruidos en octubre
de este año